season six of Deema Thrones finally
returns on Sunday and I got the cast to
reveal what's coming up in Westeros
brace yourselves winter is coming and so
is a whole lot of drama
well we got a talk when we last saw
Danny she was surrounded by some pretty
unhappy looking Dothraki yeah I know I
know when they saw me and they you know
you've got a little more unhappy there's
so much and there's so little that I can
actually tease but it she's on a journey
that's for sure the can't see
going into this season we see we're
going to see any of my beautiful green
hi
how disappointing no but actually as an
actor was really horrifying when I was
reading the script how am I going to do
this it was really really nerve-wracking
but I believe it's a really strong
storyline Ferrari and one of the
stronger she's ever had and to see like
a character take such a dip so late on
in the overall story is really
incredible
the politics and she knows how to work
her way around it it's kind of a mas
exact if it's getting people to listen
because at the end of the day people
still think she's just a spoiled little
girl from went well he needs to find her
because it's a major major problem for
him because marrying a start really
consolidates the boltons position in the
north because everyone hates the vols
everyone loves the start so without a
week in this position dramatically so
it's a big problem for him miss Ella I
mean he was he was going on a mission to
bring back their his and Circe's
daughter and he kind of accomplished
that but obviously so close yet so far
away it's kind of heartbreaking for him
and now he's gonna have to deal with his
sister she might not like it you know
hey guys we know I'm sworn to secrecy
much yes you would be right in assuming
happy body brands meeting his magical
tree cave
he's been trading up over the years when
he comes back he's still not quite a pro
with his visions but he's pretty good
with it basically you can see back in
time and maybe forward in time and we
get to see some really really cool
things this season
so many teases am so little information
not to worry guys I've already seen the
season six premiere and I can promise
that almost all of your most burning
questions will definitely be answered